when we gave our kids a phone we told
them like this is not your phone this is
my phone I'm letting you use this phone
oh wow and I don't do that because I'm
being Draconian or I'm being mean
because I afforded them their privacy
but what they needed to know
was objective right or wrong can't be
objective right or wrong because Dad
says so or because Mom says so it has to
be right or wrong because it is which
means that at some point your kids are
going to reach a certain level of of
cognition and comprehension to where
they're going to find you doing the
thing that you told them was wrong she
goes Daddy I I don't think you handled
that very well and she's about like 13
14 years old I could remember for a
split second that kind of Pride welling
up in me like oh you don't think I
handled something very well well pray
tell here's a cheat code for
Dad Nick frus welcome to my podcast
thank you very much for having me so you
got these cups but like what's the story
behind the cups so one day uh I I don't
know I was making some sort of smart
alic uh observation about something that
was going on in the news and uh I just
took a sip of my coffee at the at the
end of it because I was standing out on
my front
porch and um people apparently thought
it was funny because every other reel I
did after that people would ask where
where's your coffee mug it doesn't hit
the same without the coffee mug and
before I knew it people were sending me
coffee mugs and so yeah that's that's
become a thing now at the end of our
reels and our YouTube shorts is I
usually have some sort of uh witty uh
statement on a coffee mug or something
like that that that I'll finish off the
Reel with well it's funny I've been very
entertained good I think so I wanted to
do this podcast and kind of focus it on
kids because I've seen like a lot of
your content on Instagram is how to
raise children properly and I I haven't
done a podcast on that before and I'm
ridiculously pregnant right now so I'm
it's kind of in line with what I'm
thinking about but I thought we could
cover a bunch of quid kid questions but
before that
uh just a brief background about who you
are cuz I read that you've got well I'm
going to just butcher my description so
you should go but you're a Green Beret I
don't even know what that means so we
can start there sure so um well I'll I
kind of start I my wife and I met in
high school we got married uh gosh less
than less than a year out of high school
um I was 19 she was 20 she doesn't like
when I remind people that you know she's
N9 months older than me but um got
married out of high school I was in the
82nd Airborne Division in the United
States Army at that point um when 9911
kicked off I volunteered for Army
Special Forces better known as Green
Beret and uh kind of what makes green
beret unique within the military is we
focus a lot on unconventional warfare
counterinsurgency
counterterrorism but we work by through
and with the local population so we
operate in small 12-man teams and um we
usually like for instance when I was in
I did my tours in Iraq um I worked with
Iraqi military Iraqi militia Iraqi
police when I wasn't in Iraq we'd be in
a different foreign country training
everyone from uh Korean special missions
group to Bangladeshi border guards so
that was that was really our role in as
a green beray as we went all over the
world working with Americans uh allies
America's allies uh providing host
nation capacity and working by through
and with the local population when it
came to conducting combat operations but
I uh did that for a while got out in 200
n um shortly after my second tour in
Iraq uh my wife and I have three kids
all of them were born when I was in the
military my oldest daughter now is 21
and about to get married herself my son
just turned 18 and my youngest daughter
is about to turn
16 and um when I got out of the military
I still did some work kind of within the
the defense uh area um we've also
homeschooled for for quite a while which
I I have to give my my wife the vast
majority of the credit for that and um
and I also uh you know although I don't
like to admit it in public uh I'm also
an elected official so I serve in the
Virginia House of delegates as a as a
state legislator and I I always joke
that um yeah I I once was a a soldier
which I considered an honorable
profession and then I became a filthy
politician hey guess who's not pregnant
this girl that's right I'll update you
guys about the baby soon in a Q&A he is
so cute I can't stand it and I'm so
tired I have enough energy for ads and
that's it that's why this episode was
delayed a week
so check out after party buy it for
Christmas and the holidays and new
years's and you will thank me buy it for
people you like and not for people you
want to have alcohol induced brain
damage I'm joking it's hard to believe
something actually works for hangovers
but this works and it helps save your
brain from any alcohol consumption which
is not good for you even small amounts
but it's fun sometimes anyway uh Fuller
health.com code
xmas20 for 20% off I also haven't
mentioned this but it can be taken
before you drink to reduce the amount
you drink at least that's what it does
if you give it to rats so if you're
trying to drink less take it before you
drink and after and in the morning and
if you don't want to reduce how much you
drink take it as directed linked in the
comments Fuller health.com there's a
money back guarantee so you can give
them a shot with no worries on refunds
have a very merry Christmas my parents
are here I have a new baby my hormones
are more normal I like my husband again
after a few months of pregnancy hormones
life is good talk to you guys soon so I
was talking I we were watching this show
uh the other day my husband and I and um
it's called The Patriot
and H how did you and your wife
negotiate you going into the army like I
don't think I could imagine myself
marrying someone and then they decide to
go I mean serve their country I don't
know if I I could handle that so was
that something that you discussed with
her beforehand or had you had that plan
for a long time cuz you said you
volunteered after 911 so was that a I
had actually joined before I had
actually joined before so my my wife and
I were high school sweethearts uh we
started dating our our senior year of
high school and she knew I wanted to go
into the
military and so two weeks after high
school graduation I was on my way to
Fort Benning Georgia to go through
infantry basic training in Airborne
school and um we got married
let me that was in well I left in June
of
98 uh to go into the military and then
we got married in May of
99 and so when she came out I was I was
a private in the military uh she came
out to Fort Brag North Carolina I was
looking for work we were like totally
dirt poor it was uh Good Times um but
she knew I wanted to be in the military
but for it was a peacetime Army at that
point and we thought we were actually G
to get out and then we reenlisted one
more time because when you at that point
when you reenlisted the first time you
can kind of pick your duty station and
so we decided to get stationed in Hawaii
and um shortly after getting to Hawaii
911 took place and I I remember looking
at Tina there and going well I want to
volunteer to go Army Special
Forces uh because you know my attitude
was if there's going to be a war um I'm
going to be in
it and um that was that was um obviously
tough for but by the same token I I
don't think
she didn't have any expectations that I
was going to do anything different U
once that once that took place and and I
and I have to say after the first 10
years of our marriage if you add up all
the time away on on training on uh
combat tours on everything else I
probably spent half of it away from home
and so there were times where you know
we had for my first deployment we had
two kids my third or my second
deployment we had three kids um she had
to she had to go through a lot and I
always tell people the reason the reason
why I believe I have such a good
relationship with all my children is in
large part to the work that she did on
the home front when I was overseas and
when I was gone for training because it
would have been really easy for her to
get upset or bitter or angry or feel
kind of uh
left and she didn't she um she always
looked at it as we're we're both serving
we're just serving in different ways and
when I would go off to uh Iraq um she
would make little shirts for the kids
with you know my face on them and uh she
would send videos of of them you know
telling them how much they love their
daddy and I would try to send videos
back but she always reinforced to the
kids that look Daddy's got to be away
not because he doesn't love you but
because he has an important job to do
and our job is to support him and so
when I came home I didn't I didn't
receive any um bitterness or or sense of
Abandonment from my children they were
just happy to see me and and had Tina
not put in the work that she did I don't
think that would have happened
wow well good for you guys that's really
incredible to be able to navigate that
in a relationship like I said I was
watching a show the other day and I was
like I don't know I feel like I would
get resentful like I know my personality
I don't know if I could handle that uh
as a woman I don't know if I could
handle it so that's really impressive um
and that kind of that kind of Segways
into some of the questions I wanted to
ask you because I talk to uh my
followers on Instagram because I usually
ask if they have questions to see what's
poking around in people's unconscious
and there were a lot of women who asked
questions about raising strong men yeah
if the dad was either away or not
involved I was actually surprised at the
number of um women who didn't seem to
have a man in their life that were
saying hey I realize that this isn't an
ideal situation how do I make sure I
don't raise you know what how do I make
sure I raise a strong man so if you were
away for part of the you know periods of
childhood that means Tina your wife I
guess would have handled discipline in
those instances maybe when they were
younger so how do you think you guys
Managed IT well I think there's a a
couple of things um we we actually we we
get asked this so much on Instagram that
we finally did a video on it where we
just said what they don't tell what they
don't tell moms about raising young men
and um both team and I grew up in in
homes where our parents were
divorced and um my father was still very
influential in my life but I got to see
my dad during the Summers primarily and
then he would come up for various events
or holidays or things like that but I I
would go down to Southern California and
spend the time with my dad um and so I
didn't get to see my dad as much as I
would have liked he didn't get to see me
as much as he would have liked um but he
was still involved and so that that put
a you know that put some additional
stress on on my mom one of the things
that was um very beneficial for that is
I had great grandfathers my grandfathers
were outstanding so were my grandmothers
as well but when it came to being able
to provide a positive male role model
and influence in my life um both of my
grandfathers were were critical to that
purpose and um I I think that's one of
the things that I I would would tell
women that are growing up or that are
trying to raise young men in a less than
ideal situation because that's the other
thing I don't want a sugarcoat here
anybody that tells you that oh it's fine
you can do it you just got to be strong
no um it's not ideal it wasn't meant to
be this way you weren't supposed to have
to raise your son without a father in
the household to both assist you and
help you and help your son become a man
and also help your daughters understand
what it is uh what a positive
relationship with a man looks like um so
it is difficult for moms to try to find
those positive male role models
sometimes it's in the form of a pastor
sometimes it's in the form of a coach um
sometimes it's in a form of of a family
member like a like an uncle or or a
grandfather
sometimes it's in the form of your son's
friend who has a a a great dad in his
life that is willing to help kind of
play that role and help provide some of
that Guidance the one thing that I will
tell uh single moms and and I don't say
this to scare them I say it just because
it's it's a fact it's a reality is that
there are other men uh that will see
that as a vulnerable situation and
attempt to take advantage of it and so
the mother does have to play a role
where she is protective um of her son's
innocent especially when he's in those
vulnerable formative years um and it
isn't able to discern what a what a
threat looks like in the form of another
man so I would just tell um single moms
it is possible uh my mom did an
excellent job of it I am I have a
wonderful relationship with my mother
I'm maternally grateful for I that's one
of the things I I talked about in that
video about women raising young men was
how grateful I was for some of the
things that my mom did so try to find
those positive Mill Role Models they're
necessary um you know a father cannot be
completely replaced by a mother anym
than a mother can be replaced by a
father the other thing I will say is
that um one of the things that that
happens I think between and I and I and
I say this obviously not based off of my
own experience from a mother's
perspective but talking to my own mother
talking to my wife
um my wife was nervous about having a
little boy um she was nervous about it
we we had our oldest daughter first and
um so she wasn't she wasn't sure
and the moment he was born oh my gosh
that that little boy stole her heart
like you would not believe that that was
her little man and um there's this
there's this thing when a when a little
boy um is small his mother is Wonder
Woman right she's the most you know
beautiful wonderful
incredible you know human being on the
planet and um he's who she goes to to
make the world better right when it
doesn't make sense to him when he gets
hurt whatever it is right you know Mommy
can pick you up up snuggle you give you
a kiss on the boooo and all of a sudden
it's healed right she's she's just it
really is somewhat like
magical when your little boy starts to
get older though um a lot of the things
that made your little boy feel loved or
supported or safe or secure when they
were little starts to make them feel
weak or vulnerable as they get older and
this this varies based off of the boy
and the situation that they're growing
up in but I would say for for most of
them it's probably around Junior High uh
maybe a little bit earlier for some
maybe a little bit older for others a
lot of it depends on on the environment
they're in when they're you know going
to school or
educated um what they're exposed to and
what at what age um if you can protect
your your son's innocence um for as long
as you can which and and by protecting
the Innocents I don't mean not exposing
them to things that are age appropriate
or difficulties or challenges that needs
to happen it's part of their development
but about things that are not age
appropriate um um but at some point
they're going to get their butt kicked
at
school or something's going to happen or
they're going to in a fight and the the
Instinct that Mom has is I'm going to
step in and I'm I'm going to protect
them and look if if there's something
dangerous going on you need to do that
I'm not suggesting otherwise however
your little boy doesn't want the bully
to be afraid of mom he doesn't want the
bully to be afraid of the principal he
wants the bully to be afraid of him he
wants to feel strong and capable and so
there's things that a mom can do
that can kind of call out that protector
and that provider um that a that are
components of being a good man I I don't
care what the the new gender Norms say
about what we're supposed to do I could
care less about the studies coming out
of the sociology department at Kell
Berkeley a good man can protect and a
good man can provide and one of the ways
that my mom did that for me when I was
growing up was simple stuff right when I
was uh you know 8 nine 10 years old it
was helping her carry heavy things um it
was you know I get a little B older it's
opening up the the jar it's um you know
when you and Mom are walking down the
street and and he's 13 14 years old he
should walk on the street side he should
be opening the door for mom um he should
be treating her he he should have start
to develop an awareness um of protecting
and
providing um and and again that the
father can teach them how to do that but
the mother's the first person they
actually get to for lack of a better
term practice
with and uh and it's very important for
their development so calling out that
that protector and provider in your son
when they get into that those those you
know 12 13 14 years old 15 years old
where you uh expect it of them and you
reward them when they do it whe whether
it be with simple praise or with just
saying you know hey thank you for doing
that or you know I I hey I appreciate
you you know protecting mommy or taking
care of mommy or whatnot um what that's
doing is it's it's reinforcing in in his
mind that there's an expectation that he
does this and that when he does it it's
appreciated and that when he does it
with respect and nobility it's
appreciated and that all prepares him uh
to be able to perform with courage in
the moments when that's
necessary and again it's it's difficult
I'm not pretending it's easy um but I
can remember the first time that my son
found himself in a situation where it
wasn't dangerous to his well-being but
it was difficult and it was it was you
know potentially
physical and um me telling Tina is like
he's got to figure this out she well
well but I I can call up I just want to
talk to the the you know the other mom
about like nope he gets to figure it
out um how old was he he was
probably I think he was 12 at that point
he's got to figure it out and it does
doesn't mean they're always going to win
the fight that's important um but it's
one of those things where I'm hey I'm
proud of you for standing up for
yourself I'm proud of you for standing
up for that other child I'm proud of you
you know for doing that now again that
doesn't mean if it's a dangerous
situation you can't still call the
principal and say I just want you to be
aware of this but don't create a false
sense of security in your son's mind
that when something goes bad mommy takes
care of it for him um because one of two
things is going to happen he's either
going to have this expectation where he
never develops the necessary skill sets
both verbal and
physical um or he's going to grow a
sense of entitlement to where whenever
there's a challenge well that's mommy's
job to take care of and you don't want
to raise a little narcissist and you
don't want to raise a coward and you
certainly don't want to raise a cowardly
narcissist oh my
gosh um but those are just some of the
things that you can do to again what I
what I call calling out the the
protector and provider and your son um
and and I those are just a couple
obviously this is not comprehensive but
those are a couple things that I think
can help um help a mom or a single mom
kind of work those of those issues and
also help maintain that positive
relationship with with her with her son
as he gets older because the way all
right I'm gonna have to say this without
choking up uh the way I ended that
video is I explained that when my wife
was having our first child uh it was a
very difficult uh
delivery and when Lily was born uh she
had had the umbilical cord wrapped
around her her neck twice um when she
was when she they finally got her out uh
she wasn't breathing she wasn't moving
and uh Tina was bleeding and they
couldn't stop it and my mom was an OB
nurse and she was there with us and I
remember
um feeling about as helpless as I
possibly could and to give you some to
give you some background at this point
feeling helpless was not a sensation I
was familiar with
um at this point I was I was an
infantryman I was Ranger school sniper
School Airborne school I just passed
Special Forces uh selection I was about
to go become a Green Beret I was an
infantry squad leader like I I was
pretty confident in my ability to handle
myself and take care of situations and
now I found myself in a situation where
I could do nothing my little girl is not
breathing my wife is potentially
bleeding out on the table and I'm
sitting there
helpless dang and there was there was my
mom right there's my mom being being
there being strong like honey it's going
to be okay they know what they're doing
don't worry I'm watching over here
sweetheart hold tetin his hand you so
even at that point through all of that
through all the work that she had done
to develop me into the sort of man that
she wanted me to be and I appreciated
that at that
moment I was still just a big guy that
that wanted
uh wanted Assurance from his his mother
and uh there she was to provide it so
yeah oh man that almost got
me gets me every time oh wow um how much
of that information that you just gave
out regarding specifically raising boys
can be converted over if you have a
daughter like I've always
wondered as so I have a six-year-old
girl um and I know how I was raised and
I think you know I'm I'm alive things
are pretty good so I think that worked
out well but uh I was definitely left to
my own devices to figure out tougher
situations than I think I would be
comfortable leaving to my daughter yeah
but I'm also an ex not to like Pat
myself on the back but I don't get
stressed out very easily and stressful
situations have to be pretty life and
death before I get stressed out which I
think is because I was left to solve
situations that I was extremely
uncomfortable with so at at one point do
you just follow the same steps raising a
boy and a girl and letting her figure
out these tough situations do you think
it's similar or should they be more
protected I think there's uh very
similar principles there's very
different
applications um so here's what I mean by
that um my oldest daughter when she was
in fifth grade fifth or I think it was
fifth grade she had a little girl that
um kept threatening her at school and
this is this is we we had put our kids
back in in public school for a year and
then immediately took him back out again
we're like now we're done yeah but she
had this little girl that um and and I
remember talking to to Lily about it I
said uh sweetheart here's the first
thing I want you to understand I said
the the way this little girl is behaving
and the way she's talking to you and the
things she's saying probably suggests
that things are pretty bad at home so I
I want you to have a certain element of
Grace for that but if she lays a hand on
you that's a different
story and she said well you know Daddy
our our school doesn't let us fight now
we we called said hey look this is a
problem but we also knew that just
because we told the school it was a
problem doesn't mean this girl wasn't
going to hit my daughter at lunch and I
remember taking lilan I said well
sweetheart you got to learn how to you
got to learn how to fight you got to
learn how to defend yourself so let's
walk through that and and we spent the
rest of the night just kind of going
through like okay how do you get your
hands up how do you how do you throw
hands how do you block how do you defend
yourself and I remember the first thing
she said was well well Daddy the the
school doesn't let us fight I said you
don't worry about that I'll deal with
the school but nobody has a right to lay
hands on you and you don't have the
right to defend yourself that's not a
thing so I'll deal with administrators
you just you just worry about defending
yourself and um and so we went through
that whole process and um and it was it
was funny
because toward the end of it she felt
very confident that she knew what to do
she was going to show up to school next
thing she knew what she was going to do
she was going to start a fight she
wasn't going to try to be mean she was
going to have you know grace and mercy
toward this girl but the moment she got
hit she was taking her out and that was
it and she knew Daddy had her back and
mommy had her back and nobody she was
not going to get in trouble uh for doing
that now if a boy had been doing that to
her that would have been a different
story I would have been I would have
been down there at the school and if I
would have needed to I would have called
up that boy's parents and like I'm
letting you know that if your son lays a
hand on my daughter I'm coming for you
we're not going to let a school handle
it um you and I will handle it so my
daughter's always my daugh
the thing I always reinforce to my girls
is that I wanted them to be strong and I
wanted them to be able to stick up for
themselves I taught my kids how to shoot
at a very young age and one of the
reasons why I taught my daughters how to
shoot at a very young age is because
Firearms are an equalizer for women the
the most women are not going to be able
to effectively physically defend themsel
against a determined man that is bigger
than them it's just not a thing but if
they can shoot well then it doesn't
matter how big he is and I always wanted
my girls to understand that you have a
right to be able to live in this world
and you have a right to be able to
pursue your dreams and do the things
that you want to do without having to
live in fear of the fact that you can't
physically overpower a man now let's
give you some of the tools that you'll
need to be confident in in being able to
provide for your own security not
because I think they should go through
life having to do that not because I
want them to live in a world where it
may be necessary but because I'm not
naive to the world we actually occupy
and I want my girls to be able to defend
themselves and so from a very young age
they become very comfortable with it um
but the other thing that I would say
with with raising my daughters is I
always thought that one of the most
important um roles I played on that
was making sure that I I did spend
quality time uh with them and by quality
I mean paying attention listening um
when they were really little you know
having the little tea parties and stuff
like that um even though I still had to
be gone a lot um I also thought it was
really important that they knew that
Daddy was there to protect them um both
physically and emotionally
and one of ways I I did that was by
spending the time with them but another
way that I did that and this is also
relevant for for Sons is um with the way
I treat their mother now I I treat my
wife with love dignity and respect
because she is owed that from me but I'm
also very cognizant of the fact that
what I'm also demonstrating is I'm
showing my son how he should behave and
treat uh his wife one day and I'm
showing my daughters I'm demonstrating
for them how they deserve to be treated
by a man that they will potentially led
into their
lives and um I think that's I think
that's very important not that it's not
also important for Sons but I do think
it's very important for fathers to be
able to play that role for their
daughters uh the other thing I always
encourage dads to do is I said look as
much as as much as your little girl
might be embarrassed or your daughter
might be embarrassed by the idea of you
threatening to beat up the boyfriend or
whatnot she wants to know that you would
do it it um by the same token she
doesn't want you to flip out when a boy
likes
her and one of the things that I used to
tell my girls when they were getting a
little bit older and boys were taking an
interest was I would always tell them I
said look we got some strict rules with
respect to dating and you know that but
I want you to understand that the reason
why we have these rules is not because
we're trying to deprive you of of
something it's because we want you to
have the sort of relationship that your
mother and I have we want you to be in a
relationship that is safe and that is
secure but that is also exciting and
passionate and there's certain things
that facilitate that and then there's
certain things that hamper or harm that
and if if a boy likes you then for me
what that says is that at least at the
very least he's got reasonably good
judgment because he he likes you and and
you're you are beautiful and you're
intelligent and you're wonderful and
what boy wouldn't like you um but the
reason why we tell you that it's it's
appropriate to wait we had the same
rules for my son uh was because we want
someone worthy of you and when you meet
the person worthy of you you want to be
worthy of
them and so that means thinking about
this and and not looking so much at what
you can't have right now but looking
forward to what you will have one day if
you do this
right and so I think all of those things
uh packaged together from a father's
perspective helped
um you know again and and I I still have
to give my wife the majority of the
credit for everything but I think it did
help create an atmosphere with my
daughters where they knew that I loved
them uh they knew I would tell them the
truth even when it was difficult they
knew that I also expected them to be
able to think the through think through
things and figure out their own problems
uh but that I would I would still always
be there for them even if they had to
tell me something that I didn't want to
hear uh because ultimately I'm I'm on
their side no matter what but um and so
that that's you know some of the things
that i' I've I've learned and i' I hope
I Faithfully executed with with my own
daughters that was
beautiful all my I think these pregnancy
hormones are going be more emotion than
I usually have that was really nice hey
guys if you're still in need of a last
minute Christmas gift or you want to
positively impact your health Without
Really any effort you should get an air
purifier if you haven't already I use
AER Oasis they're super quiet they
filter down to 0.003 microns which
matters it means they actually trap
fractions of mold spores bacteria and
viruses up to 99% of them this is partly
thanks to they overlapping five
professional grade Technologies of HEPA
filtration carbon filtration germicidal
UV light ionization and silver Ion
Screen I believe they're the best
quality air filters out there they're
the best quality air filters I've found
and that matters you don't want to buy
one that doesn't filter the proper size
it just won't work as well air filters
won't be all you need to be healthy
obviously but they will help limit your
exposure to air pollutants and wow does
that make a difference it's very
noticeable go to AER oasis.com
Pages slmp or press the link in the
comments and use code MP a checkout
it'll give you an extra 10% off your
purchase these are really worth
investing in I hope you enjoy the rest
of this episode my dad told me when I
was little
this was a joke actually but I was in
kindergarten and he goes okay first day
of kindergarten class find the biggest
kid in your class and sock him then
you'll be on
top the friends over yeah that was
anyway that was a joke obviously but in
grade two I did I did get like people
public school is crazy public school is
a crazy place um my daughter's not in a
public school because it wasn't great
you really get thrown in with everybody
and it wasn't a good experience for me
but I had somebody uh some girl in grade
two I was in grade two or three that
came over and gave me like a good kick
just out of the blue she was just the
mean girl in class she just walloped me
and I like turned around and I kicked
her as hard as I could like directly
right back and then we were on that was
it that was the bullying she was like
okay and then we were she was kind of
friendly to me after that it was just
this and I've had so many I've got quite
a few liberal friends who are now having
kids whose kids are getting like bullied
in in daycare a little bit being pushed
around and they're being taught go get a
teacher I was like I don't know I don't
think the go get a teacher especially if
you're a little boy like you were saying
it's like no you've got to fix these
problems right away kids don't care what
the teachers going to say if they're
already being bad they're already in the
bad Zone yeah yeah know it's it's funny
whenever whenever somebody asks a
homeschooler about what about
socialization I'm like have you looked
at Public Schools lately are you are you
comfortable with that
socialization that's very true okay that
that's very true I know um I didn't
understand when I was in it but looking
back on it I went to like an art school
and uh I was exposed to so many things
that I wouldn't be comfortable with
exposing my kids to it was just like a
downtown public school but was like whoa
people were doing drugs in like when
they were 13 that's actually doesn't
happen at every school or like you can
actually have that not happen to a kid
it doesn't have to happen to a kid
anyway I turned out just fine but uh it
was a wild ride that's for
sure okay taking a bit of a different
direction and this is something I've
struggled with I think as a woman
because I was raised by a stay-at-home
mom uh and so I always grew up thinking
if I was going to be a good mom I had to
be a state at home mom and then when I
felt like I was missing doing other
things I had this horrible guilt complex
of well I'm supposed to be completely
fulfilled being a stay-at-home mom and
I'm not and I'm getting resentful and I
can feel that and I'm very aware of that
emotion because it just destroys your
life you can't especially as a more
agreeable person you don't want
resentment to take over your life um and
so I've managed to like make it where I
have a six-year-old we have a great
relationship everything's fine now but
how as a parent do you to balance
ambition and doing things for
yourself to fulfill yourself as well as
being the parent at home that your
children need sure well and and look at
at this point my my wife has managed the
home pretty much since we've we've had
kids so she she worked before we had
kids and we had talked about this before
we got married and I I had always asked
you know I said I look at as my job as
being the primary bread winner in the
home home that's not to say that my wife
can't work or have an income or anything
like that but I still look at it as my
primary
responsibility and um and she said well
that's great I agree and uh when we have
kids I don't want to have to work like
if if I might still but I don't want to
have to I said okay so my job is to make
enough money to where you don't have to
do that and um we didn't we didn't count
on homeschooling originally when we had
talked about this this is something that
just kind of happened initially when I
got out of the military as a practical
matter and then it became something of a
a moral matter as we looked at what was
going on within the school system um now
I I will say that I I think that there
are I think there's some women that I I
think I think most women as as a as
something of a maybe a stereotype of one
that plays out generally have um a
significant nurturing
capability um and and they want to be
able to exercise that now some people
are entirely content with managing a
home and and I like to refer to it that
way because some people you know I've
never really been comfortable with a
stay-at-home mom and I realize it's the
common vernacular but I always say that
Tina manages the home because when it
comes to our home and the fact that we
kind of you know we have animals and we
have a pretty extensive garden and we
kind of in with the homestead culture
and whatnot um there's a lot that goes
with that the other funny thing is that
my wife is the I'm going to totally lose
points for this my wife's the handyman
in the house like
I she's she's the one that where I
remember we when we moved in uh to the
last house we had there was a water
issue and she's like I'm not paying
$6,000 for someone to come in and put
this filter I can figure it out on
YouTube and she did like it it's she's
just
incredibly uh handy when it comes to
like the table that I'm sitting at right
now she built because we couldn't find
one that we wanted and she's like I'll
build it and so she never built one
before she's like I can figure it out I
like I like doing this so she has found
things that uh that allow her to um to
continue to develop the sort of skills
for which she has an interest that are
also either U marketable or just
incredibly
valuable to to the house to the business
to everything that we do at the same
time that it it allows her to be able to
assist with our kids on the
homeschooling and and maintaining the
house and everything else so I I think
what's important is is that as you look
at your kids and again I was raised by a
single mom who was a nurse she was
working quite a bit I have a great
relationship with my mom it's not like I
felt like I I missed out on everything
cuz my mom wasn't there when I got home
from school every day um but I do think
you have to look at the personality of
your kids and and part of part of
getting married and part of having
children is they become part of your
ambition they become part of your your
life's Mission and your journey um
people ask me sometimes why'd you get
married so young it was like because I
wanted to build a life with her right I
didn't I didn't want to go out and do a
bunch of stuff and then get married I
wanted to do these things with her like
my my life is so much more enriched with
her being a part of all of it and then
when you have kids it's there's it's the
same thing but once again aspects of
your life's ambition change and there
are sacrifices that have to be made
there there's no question about that the
thing that I have
found is that the the sacrifices or or
maybe the things that you um give up
or aspects maybe you don't give up the
whole thing but aspects you you you give
up because now you got to make time for
another human being um I can't think of
anything that I've had to give up on
that I I would I would go back and trade
the relationship I have with my kids for
it's not even
close and so I I think part of it is
understanding that when I got
married my wife's well-being became
Paramount to my whatever Ambitions
Ambitions I had apart from being her
husband um and and it's not like we
slowed down right I I went off to Army
Special Operations you know we we we've
done all this other stuff we we've we're
building it we're we're building a
building expanding a business right now
we we can do all those
things but it was okay how do we do this
together and then when you have kids
it's like okay how do how do we make
them a part of what we're doing um and
homeschooling allows you to do that as
well like I I love it when we we went to
a conference the while back and um it
was a homesteaders conference and Tina
had made her hinero jelly and my
youngest daughter is my total
entrepreneur and wherever she works
she'll find another way to do kind of a
side hustle and and like you know make
earrings or whatever it is and and she
did that and so you know with each one
of these
things you're it's not your ambition
goes away it expands to include people
that you love and care
about and and the space that you make to
make that all work is is worth it um and
so that that's that's what I would say
is is find ways to be able to deliver on
the passions or the or the god-given
talents and Ambitions that you have um
and then find ways that you're going to
you're going to make room to make sure
that the people that you love can
actually be a part of that and and maybe
include it in it and benefit from it as
well because if if you don't do that
what you're going to find is that you're
you're you're not going to get
everything out of uh maybe your
professional Ambitions that that you
wish you could because you're going to
feel guilty and then as you said guilt
easily turns into resentment and and
treating as if the people that you love
the most in this world are somehow
holding you back when in when in reality
there's probably a different version of
that dream or ambition which is every
bit is fulfilling and even more so
because now they get to be a part of it
um instead of isolated from it yeah that
was great I I think it's uh I think this
is probably on the Forefront of my mind
cuz I'm about to have another baby and
I'm I'm entrepreneurial too I'm
extremely entrepreneurial so if I don't
do pursue something it really eats at me
but I'm also at home all the time so I'm
with like I'm with my
daughter and so it's just I guess not a
way that I thought life was going to
turn out I had this preconceived notion
about what being a parent was like and I
don't know if anyone's pre conceived
notion of what being a parent is like is
right but mine certainly wasn't so being
flexible with homeschooling too is very
cool we could delve into that a little
bit oh it's it's there's because one of
the things one of the biggest
misconceptions about home schools people
think that you're replicating public
school at home yeah no you're not in
fact I mean look I would have left
public school just for the socialization
aspects and the and the things that were
going into the curriculum and the
teaching methods but but now I look at
it I was like well no it it afforded me
all these opportunities to be able to
adapt an educational model to actually
meet the needs of my child not perform
some sort of you know dance for the mass
production of education and and so I I
would just say that it's funny my my
wife and I uh talk and and our faith is
very important to us and they always
talk about the Proverbs 31 Woman in in
there and my wife was always like man
that's it's intimidating I'm like baby
you are that woman what are you thinking
about like you you do all this stuff and
and and you're creative and you're
productive and you're caring and you're
nurturing and you're loving and and
you're doing all of it and um and so I
do think some of the preconceived
stereotypes that we have about what what
does it look like um I think it I think
it looks like spending time and
investing in your children and and
loving them and knowing that and and
protecting their innocence
and but also allowing them to be a part
of your endeavors um so yeah when did so
you said one of your kids in particular
is entrepreneurial when did she start
that's a little girl right yeah yeah
when when did she start making things
and selling them so oh gosh probably
when she was 10 or
11 um when she was 10 or 11 she would
you know and and all of my kids have
have um all my kids have something of an
entrepreneurial streak and and can be
very very um driven in in professional
stuff my we used to tell my oldest
thought we told all of our kids when
they were young we're like we don't owe
you a college education that doesn't
mean we that doesn't mean we won't help
you but one we don't owe it to you and
and two you should probably think about
whether or not it actually makes sense
for what you want to do with your life
what you need is marketable skills you
need marketable skills so get the
marketable skills that are as close to
the dreams and passions and Ambitions
that you have that will put you in that
realm to be able to do what you would
really like to do but but as a
responsible adult you need to feed
yourself and I remember my um my oldest
daughter she loves theater and she knows
that theater is is a very very difficult
thing to make a living on so she was
looking at well I don't want to go to
college for a theater degree I want to
go I want to get a cosmetology license
because that puts me in a realm of being
able to do hair and makeup and
everything else and we said okay that's
a great idea she worked a night shift at
McDonald's and then would come home
sleep get up and work another job she
paid her entire way through it and she
did excellent she took all of the
additional courses she got all the
addition certifications she paid it off
the day she graduated and that was hers
right that wasn't something she was now
my my youngest daughter very early on
she she just had this interest for the
entrepreneurial um she liked the idea of
making things and selling things and it
and it didn't um which is crazy because
for me I wish I was more entrepreneural
like that I have such a hard time
selling you know products and stuff
right like I I just I have a hard time
with it but her whole thing was like no
I've made something I've made something
of quality that people want and I'm
going to I'm going to put it out there
and see what happens and then I'm going
to learn from what they do so at 12 13
years old she was working at or I think
it was I think it was 13 13 14 she was
working at a coffee shop and um you know
the the owner of the coffee shop
wonderful uh wonderful young woman
another young
entrepreneur and uh she was saying well
I noticed you sell some other things can
I bring my earrings in and she goes yeah
you you can bring your earrings in she
goes and and I will get a cut as the
store owner and and I'll take care of
the tax and all and you can do that and
Ally was like great so she did that and
then she moved over to a different uh
job but it was kind of a similar
situation and the lady said oh do you
want to sell your earrings over here and
allly said yeah that that'd be wonderful
she goes okay she allly goes well what
what do you want as your as your
percentage and she goes oh you don't
have to pay me anything Allie's like no
you need to get paid it's your
storefront it's your clientele it's your
customer base I'm providing an
additional service but you're providing
the storefront so no you have to get
paid
something um so I I was just very proud
that you know she she took that attitude
of not just being entrepreneurial but
understanding that this is about Mutual
benefit um so yeah do you think she
learned all that from being homeschooled
just like learning from you guys or does
that naturally happen it might naturally
happen as well I think she had a natural
inclination the difference was is that
in a homeschooling environment when you
see your kids pick up on something you
don't have to say oh that's nice but
we've got to go through 6 hours of you
know books so you can take a
standardized test we say oh that's great
you know what you should do you should
let let's bring up YouTube and let's
watch some stuff on how to do that and
let's talk about how you would do a
storefront and whether or not you can
get an Etsy account and so when you're
homeschooling like if I would have told
my son sit at this table and study for S
hours a day he would have lost his mind
and now every once in a while you have
to do that sometimes you just got to
read read the book and you got to take
the test but you know we went to a hom
school conference once and he said dad
can I take the blacksmithing class like
yeah sure why not let's let's take one
together and he really liked it we've
now got a we've now got an anvil and a a
small Forge at home and anytime like
he's bouncing off the walls it's like
dude I want you're going to go make me a
knife or you're GNA go make me this
you're going to go make me that and I
remember my wife called me up at one
point cuz I was down in Richmond for the
legend
and she goes hey babe I'm really happy
that Luke loves you know out there
blacksmithing but I'm not thrilled when
he's pounding on steel at midnight
because you gave him a
Deadlight so oh that's
funny oh I like the idea though of
introducing you know tools say
blacksmithing for instance um as a way
to well to give them something to do to
like release tension that's cool I like
that when and we wanted to give them
something productive to do while
releasing yeah make some knives that's
awesome um how did you manage social
media in your household did you just ban
it did you allow some of it what we
allowed some of it we allowed some of it
and and that's one thing too that I look
back sometimes and I'm wondering okay
how would I how would I have done this
differently um we never had cable really
with the kids um past the age of like
five or something like that so we did a
lot more on managing what they watched
um and it was interesting because we
were homeschooling and again they still
had a lot of interaction with other kids
and and everything but they never they
never got into like pop culture Trends
so like our kids were watching I Love
Lucy and Little House on the Prairie and
they thought it was awesome because it's
just what they watched with each other
and with Mom and Dad and they got
invested in the characters and um one of
the
biggest here's a cheat code for
dads I had my wa daughters watching Jane
Austin
adaptations so BBC has a bunch of really
really good Jane Austin adaptations my
two favorite are Sense and Sensibility
and Pride and Prejudice now I know this
sound like quick story I was at a pub
with a bunch of my military buddies and
they were having trivia night and one of
the questions was name all the Jane
Austin novels that don't have and in the
title and I walk over to a table full of
women I'm like yeah it's it's Emma and
North Ranger ab and Mansfield Park and I
I was never here cuz I'm not supposed to
know that right I'm a dude but Jane
Austin's brilliant the reason why I tell
dads this is because one the dialogue is
incredible so much dialogue in modern
movies suck Jane Austin was was
brilliant with with dialogue and her
insults were just top tier stuff right
topnotch yeah but I remember my oldest
daughter she was about 12 at the time
watching um a movie we had been watching
a lot of Pride and Prejudice and and
North rer Abbey and and Mansfield Park
and all this stuff and she's watching a
different movie and she goes oh my gosh
Daddy what he goes that girl just kissed
that boy I said what happened she goes
daddy they're not engaged she's going to
lose her character and I'm like yes
you're right that's she goes daddy did
you kiss Mommy before you were
engaged let's get some ice
cream but but the the and I forgot where
I was going with all this I remember the
original question
um but anyways so so we we got to
control lot what their media intake was
when they were at their most formative
years yeah and then when they got a
little bit older and it came time to
where um they could actually go places
either they could drive or they were
going places with their friends or or
whatnot
um that's when we gave them a phone and
the moment you give your kids a
smartphone right there there's there's a
certain degree of access that they're
going to have to that and so the way
that we managed it was was was very
simple when we gave our kids a phone we
told them like this is not your phone
this is my phone I'm letting you use
this phone and I'm letting you use this
phone because you're going places I want
you to be able to call me if you ever
get yourself in a in a you know bed and
it's not like they were going out
partying with friends till you know
midnight this is like going for you know
whatever um they were all going out to
the movies right and they were going to
be home by 9: or something but I still
want them to have a phone when they're
away from me so that they can they can
call me if if they need
me but what that did was it created a a
whole different set of expectations and
and we did this with the rooms as well
like you don't have a room I have a room
I let you use the room oh wow and I
don't do that because I'm being
Draconian or I'm being mean because I
afforded them their privacy but what
they needed to know was they were not
allowed to do things in my house or on
my phone or anywhere else to where if I
said I want to see your phone or I want
to see your room it wasn't Dad how dare
you invade my privacy because the
expectation was is they knew it was the
room I let them use it was the phone I
let them use and so the the expectation
of ownership was very different and so
when I said so now if you're using that
phone and you're doing something
inappropriate on social media or you're
looking at something inappropriate I get
to check your phone and oh by the way I
I've got a I've got a degree in
intelligence management and cyber
security you ain't hiding anything on
your phone that I can't
find um but I never really had to it's
not like we we did a bunch of like spot
inspections and and came into the room
once a week and checked everything or
lined them up and hand over their phones
we had a close enough relationship with
our kids where we can tell when
something was off and every once in a
while I'd be like hey I need to see your
phone um and it was here you go it
wasn't I'm angry it wasn't I'm mad it
wasn't you're spying on me it wasn't any
of that it was this is Dad's property
dad and mom's property and and they're
asking for it back and they have every
right to do that and and as a result we
did let them have limited social
media but once again we always had the
right to check whatever they would do
they would friend us immediately on on
uh their accounts and the funny part was
is that initially um you know they they
would do they love to do like little
funny videos and stuff like that and and
again both of my daughters were very
into theater and so it provided another
outlet for them to do kind of funny
videos and and they they doing things
inappropriate um now there's going to be
some people that watch this and be like
oh that guy's just naive okay you can
think that if you want um there's no way
for me to prove to you that I that I
that's not the case um all I can tell
you is that if if and my daughters have
been on my my oldest daughter's been on
my podcast before um you're you're
welcome to sit down and and you know
watch that and and tell me whether or
not you think that she doesn't possess
the emotional maturity uh to be able to
deal with that and understand that it
can be both an advantage and it can also
be a horrible disadvantage if it's used
inappropriately or wrong and so I I do
think that we um we certainly tried and
I think we achieved it for the most part
of establishing a healthy enough
relationship with all of our kids that
when we told them to stay away from
something or they weren't allowed to
have something um there there wasn't a
great deal of questioning on whether or
not we were doing it because we loved
them we were never doing it to be
tyrannical um one of the biggest
problems I think a lot of parents face
right now is they will say things like
well we didn't raise you that way
whenever their kids
Rebel uh especially if they go off to
college and I I usually have to look at
and be like well what did what did you
do when they asked you questions or they
asked you why or they questioned you on
something and it's and the parents that
say things like well because I say so or
because you live under my roof or
because I take care of you I said well
no then your kids are doing exactly what
you taught them to do which is to obey
Authority it's just you're not the
authority anymore
yes so
so interesting okay so like I had a
couple of thoughts come up during that
so I know I was quite sick as a teenager
like I was on medication I had an
autoimmune disorder and I was a mess um
so I'm sure that played into a role with
instability uh in my life
um but I remember getting a phone and I
mean nobody had like people didn't
really have phones and I had a phone
late but I got my own phone and I feel
like if my parents had said something
like this is my phone you can't have one
I would have just cuz I had a bunch of
jobs I would have just figured out how
to Lion schem and get one and then I
would have hidden it so I was like how
did you avoid having the kind of kids
that would just be like you know that
would do it anyway but maybe just from I
mean I suppose having kids at home and
uh teaching them from home helped oh it
helped I think that was just that was
just communication between you guys and
like they knew that it was in their best
interest what you were telling them was
in their best interest I it's a
combination of factors they I will I
will chalk a lot of it up to
homeschooling and and again would would
a lot of people here when they hear
homeschooling is isolation we didn't
isolate our kids our our kids went all
over the place like I I had to campaign
across the entire State my kids went
with me we did stuff they they used so
it's not like they were unaware of what
was going on in the world but by the
same token I wasn't having to compete
with a bunch of you know influences like
negative influences you like you said
when you show up to a public school
class you might have the greatest
teacher on the planet the teacher
doesn't pick the curriculum right you
you may you may have parents that you
really like you don't know what's going
on in the homes of all the kids that are
sharing that classroom and sharing that
environment with your child and you
don't know what ideas they're getting
exposed to you don't know what concepts
they're getting exposed to and then the
popular culture thing and this
expectation of well Sally's mom said
that you know de I don't care I don't
really have to deal with that um and so
but by the same token we didn't shelter
our kids like they got a phone phone
there was just rules governing the phone
um but so much of it was about man so
much of it was about managing what
appropriate expectations look like and
the other thing too that was really
important and this is something that my
parents established with me very early
on if you lie to me I I guarantee you
whatever you've done is nowhere near as
bad as if you've done it and lie to me
about it if you tell me the truth we can
work through that if you lie to me I
can't trust you and not going to treat
you like a responsible person I'm
certainly not going to treat you like uh
like you know an adult as you start to
approach those years if you lie to me
and so we we never really had a problem
with our kids lying in part because I'm
going to chalk it up to two things in
part because we we really did try to
explain why we were doing what we were
doing and and we'd let them ask
questions here was the other thing um
that was pretty
critical there will if you teach your
kids that there is such a thing as
objective right and
wrong objective right or wrong can't be
objective right or wrong because Dad
says so or because Mom says so it has to
be right or wrong because it is which
means that at some point your kids are
going to reach a certain level of of
cognition and comprehension to where
they're going to find you doing the
thing that you told them was wrong so
what happens when they call you on it
and the story I always tell people
because it it's it's just burning my
memory
I came home from work at one day I was
very stressed out I come in my two
youngest kids are in the kitchen Luke
and Ally are in there and they are
making a mess right that's all I see
they are making a mess of the kitchen
and I'm angry because I'm already
mad and I didn't do a good job of
leaving work on the doorstep before I
came in so I go in there I'm like I
don't know what you guys are doing in
here but stop it right now clean up the
room clean this up well Dad I don't want
to hear it clean it up and then I
stormed
upstairs so my oldest daughter comes up
knocks on the door
and uh yeah what is it she goes Daddy
can I can I talk to you for a minute I
said ' okay what what do you
need she goes Daddy I I don't think you
handled that very well and she's about
like 13 13 14 years old and I I could I
could remember for a split
second that kind of Pride welling up in
me like oh oh I you don't think I
handled something very well well pray
tell I had no idea you were such an exp
ERT on these things and I remember
stopping myself and and it was almost
like that moment of like quick
prayer where it was like okay my
daughter just had the courage to knock
on the door asked me if she could talk
to
me and then had the courage to tell me
that she thought I didn't handle
something very well and she's doing this
all very respectful she's not being
snotty she's not being arrogant she's
she's being very
respectful and I remember catching
myself and going okay what is it
and she goes Daddy the reason why Luke
and Ally were in the kitchen was because
they got permission from Mommy to make
something for
you and that's what they were trying to
do and now they're too scared because
you're angry to tell you that's what
they were
doing and I remember just thinking oh my
gosh I mean not not only have I just you
know lost all my father of the year
points with my two youngest children but
now my my 13-year-old
daughter has just confronted me with
something when I'm already in a bad mood
and she is 100%
correct and and I looked at her at that
moment and and there but there by the
grace of God go
I I said
sweetheart you're right and I'm wrong
and I'm GNA go down I'm going to
apologize to them I said but I I want to
thank
you I want to thank you for having the
the courage and to do it
respectfully so you did the right thing
I appreciate it I'll go apologize to to
Luke and
Ally and um I I think what that
did and l l lily and I have talked about
this since I I think what that did was
it helped reinforce the idea that the
rules that Tina and I were setting out
for our kids were not rules because we
said
so um they were rules because they were
tired they they were tied to an
objective morality and like I said our
faith is really important to us and this
is always the part where people get
upset with me where I say look I don't
know I don't know how to give you the
worldview without telling you about the
author of it um so if if the rules came
from God right then my job is to
Faithfully execute them and Faithfully
raise my children to understand right
and wrong and and to
to to behave in a trustworthy honest
Noble loving and merciful
way and when I violate that if my
response to my child is how dare you you
say this to me this is my house I put
food in your belly clothes on your back
and a roof roof over your head you don't
question me you don't challenge me you
haven't taught them right or wrong
you've taught them an
unbridled almost slavish obedience to
Authority and and you may think well
they're under your Authority that that
works out just fine but what you've
actually taught them is that and then
all of a sudden one day you wake up and
you find you're not the authority
anymore and it may be a teacher it may
be a professor it may be a friend group
it may be a boss it may be a boyfriend
or a girlfriend or whatever it is but
then all of a sudden when they don't
know how to handle themselves in in a
difficult situation when they don't have
the courage the capability or the
capacity to stand up and tell Authority
no you're wrong and to do so
respectfully but to do it
nonetheless then you set your child up
for
failure and I'm I'm I'm
very I'm very grateful um for the fact
that I've I've now had an opportunity to
to witness or hear about from
others times when my children have stood
up in difficult situations and said no I
I don't think that's right whether it
was to friends whether it was to peer
group whether it was to a boss whether
it was to a teacher whatever it was to
do so respectfully but to do it
nonetheless when it could have cost them
something and and I think it's one of
the most important roles that we play as
parents and and I have to tell you I
it one of the most formative one of the
most formative ways you will probably
teach your children that and I don't
think you should set this up or
intentionally do it but one of the most
formative ways you will probably teach
your children that is when you fail and
they respectfully call you on it and you
have the presence of Mind in that moment
to not only admit you were
wrong um but thank them thank them for
it
yeah it's funny so you're talking about
faith I was uh I was brought up I wasn't
brought up in a in a uh like an atheist
household it was more like agnostic
understanding the importance of the
Bible and of Christianity but
without believing in it if that makes
sense sure cultural relevance but you
yeah cultural relevance but also
relevance to why you should
act you should try to act like Jesus
because
it makes your life like inexplicably
better but without believing in it it's
like hard to explain so it was kind of
it was a noble
myth yes exactly exactly that um and so
one of the main rules in my household
like the rule in my household was do not
lie and it was hard to wrap my head
around that cuz I didn't understand
especially from a Christian perspective
I didn't understand the right the
difference between right and wrong
because I didn't didn't really
understand the difference between good
and evil that that those were actual
things in the world I I thought things
were more nuanced than that um and so I
didn't lie I just got in trouble all the
time for not doing what I was told to do
but then I'd say well well you told me
not to lie this is what I'm doing and
I'm not going to stop doing it but I'm
not going to lie about it so that that's
how I was brought up I think it would
have been such a relief to be brought up
knowing that there was good and evil
because it's so hard to understand the
world if you don't believe that es
especially with like in terms of other
people cuz I think I only really figured
this out when I was maybe 26 or
27 that regardless of what happens in
somebody's
past that person can turn into a very
bad person even if what made them bad is
heartbreaking and almost understandable
it doesn't really matter how you got
there if what you ended up is is is an
evil individual yeah and I think I was
completely naive to to people and the
evil of people until much more recently
although were you raised were you raised
a Christian is this something that you
grew up with yeah I I was I was raised I
was raised in what you might call uh
kind of like a charismatic uh
Christianity and so I I always felt
that I I I believed in
it but I I also felt like there was
something missing it it seemed overly
emotional uh to me and it it wasn't
until I was in the military and um I I
had there was another guy I was I was
serving in the military with who I I
really respected as a I really respected
as a man I respected him as in in SF
what we would call an operator um in
vernacular terms probably like or or in
common terms would be like a warrior
right that's I I respected this guy as
as a man who could handle himself and do
his job and and whatnot and he was very
Unapologetic in his faith but at the
same time it was very
um he could debate it he could debate it
very effectively on a philosophical
level on a scientific level on a
mathematical
level and uh we we would find ourselves
in in situations as we were going
through this course where you know him
and I would be debating other people and
he he looked at me once he goes have you
ever have you ever looked into Christian
apologetics I like what's
that and um he said I I think I think
you would be very interested and so I
went down this Rabbit Hole of you know
William Lane Craig and Oz Guinness and
um I mean Frank Turk and well Frank Turk
later on and um you know Cornelius
vantil and Greg bonson and and in in
addition to really pouring into the
Bible and attempting to understand it
not just you know apply it or or say oh
this is this is yes of course this is
true because this is nice and good and
this is what I've been taught but really
really critically looking at it and
being like is this true does this
explain things well
and um and and that's the part where in
my own faith that that time of testing
where it was I want to believe what's
true I don't I don't I don't want to
believe what just is utilitarian in
nature oh this works because it just
does and let's not get to the bottom of
why it does and what I discovered
through a very critical analysis of my
own
faith was that I believed it I believed
it earlier in life because it was
convenient believed it later in life
because I because it's
true and because I felt like it um it
did the the best job of explaining The
Human Condition
um and I and I found it to be incredibly
logically consistent and and all of
those things factored in heavily into my
faith because here's what you here's
what you end up discovering if if you
are if you are believing in Christianity
because it's easy I don't know what
Christian it you're subscribed to but it
isn't the one it isn't the one I'm I'm
committed to um and I think I think it
was GK Chesterton that that said that it
is not that um it's not that
Christianity has been tried and found
wanting it's that it's been found
difficult and left
uned um but the what it what it does
provide and again I I don't say this
from utilitarian purpose I think it
actually explains what's going on um not
just a perspective of what's going on
but what's going on
is that it it does provide an
explanation for meaning and purpose and
identity and good and evil and what
those things mean and in a time where I
feel like the entire country is going
through an identity crisis one of the
things I always tell people is like look
I've had ups and lows I've had I've had
moments where I thought I was going to
die and never see my kids again I I've
had moments where marriage was difficult
I I've had moments where raising kids
was difficult where I you I lost a job
and I didn't know how I was going to
provide for my family like I I've I've
I've been through some stuff um harder
than some people nowhere near as hard as
many others but I've been through some
stuff but I've never had a question of
my identity I've never had a question of
my meaning or purpose in this life uh
and when things go wrong that doesn't
surprise me I expect things to be
difficult I expect there to be
challenges I expect there to be problems
to overcome and deal with because I
believe we live in a fallen world and I
believe that there's Injustice in the
world and I believe that one of one of
the one of the purposes I have in this
world is to confront this and to to
confront that Injustice in a way that
actually brings glory to the to the
person that or to the to the god that
made me um and what it also does is it
it it creates in you um whether it be
your marriage whether it be your
parenting um that that relationship that
you have with god um that relationship
you have with
Christ creates an assurance of one's
identity to where um it steals you um by
that I mean it gives you the fortitude
to be able to stand up in situations
where everybody else is is running and
and it it goes to the that verse where
it says the peace which surpasses all
understanding it's not the verse that
says the peace which everyone
understands because everything's going
smoothly it's the peace which surpasses
all understanding it's that moment in
the chaos where you can stand strong
confident in your meaning your purpose
who you are and what you're here to do
where everybody else just sees
chaos and say why why does that person
have peace in that moment and that's why
and like I said I I will I will always
get to this point where I'm talking
whether it's it's to our our podcast
audience or where people say no Nick I I
like everything you had to say but I
don't see that God has anything to do
with it I said well then you see
something I don't again I
I I can't give you the world VI without
the author um and and all I can say is
that for what it's worth I I I've come
to that conclusion not just through
emotional or or spiritual conviction but
but what I believe to be very rigorous
intellectual conviction as well um which
makes sense because scripture doesn't
tell tell you to love God with just all
your heart ad just all your emotions it
tells you to to love him with with your
with your strength with your spirit with
your mind um and I think when you when
you do that and it's a continuous
process uh but when you do that all of a
sudden things make sense even when it
gets bad yeah that was very well said um
I like that
quote um that you had about Christianity
not being easy which was my experience
because like I said growing up I knew
the psychological significance of the
biblical stories and I knew the biblical
stories pretty well but I never
understood what I didn't have the
feeling I didn't understand it more than
that and I remember looking at people
who were Christians mostly and they
seemed calmer you know even if things
weren't going well around them they just
had a type of piece and I started seeing
that more and more and then I saw it my
mom and I was just like that looks great
whatever they have looks fantastic and
if I could just get over this hump of
understanding I really want that I just
don't know how to get over it so I can
uh and then I and then I did thank
goodness um just a just a couple years
ago but I can understand where people
are coming from where they're like I
don't get it yeah it'd be yeah but um
that was spot on though it's not easier
it wasn't easy how do you look that's
why no one been able to like properly
explain uh Jesus and God to a atheist
audience there isn't an elevator like
there are elevator pitches but there's
no way to just convey the meaning in in
all the meaning unfortunately I don't
know what has to happen to you I feel
like you have to I had to hit rock
bottom rock below what I thought Rock
Bottom was for any change to happen to
me and then it happened yeah uh so very
strange
well that was interesting my husband's
the one who said hey you should get this
Nick guy on he looks great well I
appreciate it so yeah so that was that
was fantastic um thank you very much for
coming on no no really really is my
pleasure I I have a great appreciation
for for what you do and for the topics
that you bring up and for your
willingness to be able to discuss things
I I I will tell you
um as as much as I believe there need to
be um more men out there providing um
kind of an alternative uh
to some of the male backlash that's
understandably happening against
feminism um we need a lot more we need a
lot more young women that are also
willing to stand up and to be able to
either share from experiences or um to
to just be able to provide a a a
different version of what being a strong
woman looks like and so I I certainly
appreciate your willingness to to wait
into this culture this cultural
environment that we find ourselves
that's often time oftentimes hostile um
to the stances that you're taking and to
make them anyway so thank you wow well
thank you very much it was nice meeting
you you as
[Music]
well